hello yeah we've come to um to join the
ukrainian
army or whatever they're called
what they called
the foreign legion yeah okay thank you
yeah
what nationality are you british
and what's made you want to come here
they look like they need help
we're young strong fit men we can help
so why not do you have any military
expertise absolutely none at all
email a letter for this address yeah and
he contacted you and said what you must
do okay now he's giving us these details
which we're now gonna ring
um
and somehow
they're gonna tell us what we need to do
from here on why have you decided to
come down here today well um
trying to make a difference uh seen on
the news uh innocent people
losing their lives
are you prepared to lose your life
i think so yes i used to be in the ta
i've also got a lot of first aid
training
so
decided to come and do something and
you're prepared to go to ukraine and
fight yeah i can get on the flight
tomorrow and if you don't know i'm
asking how old are you
i'm 60 which means i'm just about within
the rain age range they'll accept
and you're prepared to put your own life
on the line well somebody has too